you know I get so many people that want
to do some pasta dish but we don't want
to do the noodles because of the gluten
and it's a refined carp because it's
going to turn down the sugar go fast so
you can do spaghetti squash or you can
try this incredibly simple yet delicious
meal using zucchini
all you do is
couple zucchini you get some sauce make
sure you get the sauce tomato sauce with
a low sugar so I have one that's 5 grams
of sugar per half a cup pretty low you
boil it or simmer it get it hot you can
put a little hamburger meat if you want
put mushrooms if you want and then you
need to get one of these these are
incredible so what it has is it has 12
blades across right here and it has a
horizontal and vertical blades and
you're going to actually make your
noodles with this little device right
here it's quite incredible so let me
just kind of show you how to do it cut
off the ends right here and then we're
going to going to shave it check that
out so the goal is to have noodles
without sweets pink the carbohydrates
low and have something that's nutritious
this is very similar to the spaghetti
squash but you have to cook the
spaghetti squash this is all raw so
you're basically having raw vegetable
and now I have my noodles now let's see
if the camera guy actually likes it
let's check it out
can't tell the difference really it's
pretty good isn't it it was really good
yeah I know it's surprising so you've
got to try this it's so simple to make
it's so fast and it's actually healthy
for you so if you like spaghetti check
it out